R. Ellis Frazier, Director, Producer, CEO
at BADHOUSE Studios: Three weeks later
we're going to be on some red carpet somewhere
and William Morris is going to call
someone to sign us. None of that happened.
Film Courage: You've mentioned that a
beautiful lesson for creative people
is getting knocked down. Why is that? It
sounds troubling. Why would that be good?
Frazier: It's been said a lot you don't know who
you are until you've been knocked down and figure
out who you are. Who you are is always in how you
get up and how gracefully you can get up without
retaining too much anger and resentment for
things. You're going to get knocked down
in the film business. I don't care
if you're how high up you are,
there's going to issues. When you've been
down, then you can get up. We had a film
that we were going to do that was going to be
this bigger film. It was going to be the one that
goes up and up. It got all the way to location
scouting everything we had production offices
everything and something happened and the
thing just the bottom just dropped out of it
and we literally were in the production
office like they said movies off we're like
what are we going to do now and a lot of people
just went their separate ways and everything else
and and I still remember how
kind of low that felt that
and then it wasn't like you try to save it oh
maybe we can go over here and somebody will do
it and that didn't work so we just had nothing we
had to start over from scratch and I thought wow
what a great lesson that is what a great humbling
experience so I know now that it's not just going
to go just like I want it so we need to be able to
figure out how to bring yourself back up from that
and in that is where you learn the most
valuable lessons in life and in film
in life obviously it's how you test your your
inner strength and ability to stay focused in film
you learn how to do things that you were going to
hire three guys to do now you can hire one guy to
do and you learn that you can do it with the one
guy if you help you learn how these things all
work and how they all kind of work together
and you become a better filmmaker that way
so when when you get knocked down that's where the
lessons are I mean like I had said before the the
first film we just were kind of on cloud night we
didn't know what was going on we just knew well
three weeks later we're going to be on some
red carpet somewhere and William Morris is
going to call someone to sign us none of that
happened so the real lessons were learned after
we had that thing fought from under us and
say okay now we can rebuild now we can rebuild
with something solid where we know what we're
doing when we know how to get it done and we
can then look at a investor or look at a
distributor or someone who's giving an mg
[a minimum guarantee] or whatever and say I know
exactly how to get this film done we don't have
to depend on anybody that we don't know we know
exactly how to get it done and that confidence
in that gleam in your eye that confidence
is something that financiers want to see
that you're not thinking about how great you're
going to be that you're thinking about the film
you're thinking about their
investment you're thinking about
all the elements and that if something happens
you can fix it you're not just going to fall apart
on the ground how to pick yourself back
up and pick your production back up
and keep it moving forward that's a much better
investment than if you've never been knocked down
can you tell when you go to hire someone
or you have an interview with someone
for whatever it is whether it's a script
reading a producer and there's something in
you that knows that person hasn't been knocked
down and maybe they're not going to weather
a tougher or shoot a little something with a
little more challenge a little more edge to it
absolutely you can tell you can it's you can tell
it right in their eyes I mean you don't want to be
prejudiced against them meaning in that way but
it's a lot of times you can tell by what they
ask for if they say I need this I need that and
I need this and I and then you say well we might
have that with well how are we going
to do the film if we don't have that
well if you if you haven't done the film without
that then you might be on the wrong film because
we may have that and we may be able
to get that but it can't be like well
I you have you're doing DP stuff and the guy says
well I can't work without a focus puller well most
DPs don't want to work without a focus puller and
to have a focus point we have focus pullers but
the DPs that are doing indie films most of them
know that they've at some point had to pull their
own focus okay so if you get somebody that says
well I've never worked without a focus puller well
that may not be the right guy for us because
even though we'll give him a focus puller we
we still it's still potentially problematic that
they have maybe never been on enough films and
had those kind of experience so if something
happens that for focus puller get sick or
runs off or something they can we can still get
the film done and things don't stop unless things
go exactly the way they're supposed to go so I
think that's a decent example of it but but it
can be a lot of things it's very rare to find
an actor that has not been knocked down that
that's very common they've all had any actor
has dealt with massive amounts of rejection
massive amounts of disappointment they know they
were perfect for the role they did a perfect read
and they never got the call back or they
got the call back and then they gave the
part to the producer's girlfriend or something
like that because they're they they come in pretty
strong in that area of things not going
their way so I give them that credit to and
certainly directors and filmmakers you
go through it constantly of of having
this is going to go and it doesn't go and
this is going to go and it's going to go
it's one of the reasons we moved to Mexico we
just just stay stay with them with the real stuff
so based on what someone asks questions and their
needs you can tell how it'll work out I think so
if you ask the right questions I asked
what was the lowest budget movie you've
ever made let's say I’m worth talking a crew
member say have you ever have you done an in
if you did student type films things like
that and that'll kind of inform you as to
how cooperative they'll be and you know what do
you do if there's not enough time or daylight
what do you do and well we'll just shoot
tomorrow no you can't shoot tomorrow
what are you going to do well they can always
figure something out put the light up here like
this we'll do like this we'll bring it in close
we'll just we'll do the reverse so we see the sun
and then we'll turn around and light it this
way there's all kinds of things you can do so
you're always looking for flexibility you're
looking for people that that feel like they
can get it done regardless of the situation in
the scenario it's the most important thing so
and I don't see a lot of people that are are
really I've had to say what I can't have that
person it's not a lot most people in film have
come up through the same system of with their
friends and in student films and short films
and they've seen it all most of the time so
it's not like people coming out of some
prestigious school where they've never
seen anything I mean you you see people a lot
of people go to film school and to USC or UCLA
and that's great but everybody knows it it's on
set experience is what everybody's looking for.
What lessons have you learned
from getting knocked down?